hey Chris nice butt Wow hi everyone
welcome back to resident knievel that's
a beautiful game but that's a nice glute
some nice glutes it's Chris Redfield
this might be the final episode possibly
we might go a little longer for toward
the end we do have either way I win we
have some difficult times ahead of us in
this episode I think based on what I
vaguely remember what other people are
saying in YouTube comments I know what I
have to do Mary I Code Veronica and this
might be the end now I know that well
note our friend is glued to a wall and I
gotta cut her out with his combat first
there's a we got a number how you got
elf Fred named Alfred sees the brother
you got his ring jewel there's another
one back in the crane key we gotta go
use the crane key first well we should
and then we can go what a way to eat for
this endeavor I have a plant I have some
hell I have I have three wicked objects
I get the cranky I have a jewel you
probably get rid of this mission what
they told me to start using and get rid
of them because you can't like use them
in a boss fight yeah and you have now
I'll tell you this though I kind of want
to take my shotgun
because if on this journey I get one of
those hunters sweeper hunter things then
I think I need a shotgun right sure what
do you think yeah and then also I do you
concur yeah I concur combine those
though because I think you can free up
that space that's all right I'll just
put the last two back I don't mean them
it's unlikely I'll have to burn through
that many shotguns health is good the
combat knife you don't need yet if
you're gonna come back here first anyway
okay anything else maybe bring the
handgun in case we have three slots I
mean yeah
now you're got the handgun I don't even
think are gonna be fine these bogan
arrows to that I have not used am I
gonna use those on the boss fight
because you know you have enough
grenades for like three more resonable
games um then I feel like I could take a
bow gun and like get rid of 30 these
Boies
sure where is my bow gun wait no it's
here does the lady have them oh Claire
knows right there okay that was scary oh
yeah we have decided well we decided a
while ago but other people are asking
we're gonna do resonable zero after this
the HD origins collection version so you
won't have to battle awful tank controls
anymore yeah it's still fixed camera but
they fixed it for the ps4 version so I'm
gonna play through that probably this
weekend actually if you're watching this
episode I'm probably playing it right
now just to refresh myself I the last
few games that you've played I'm going
no yeah kind of actually if you bring up
your map it should jog alright I think
it's to where those stairs are or I
could be completely wrong in fact I
think I am it no that pink elevator
across the hallway right no I don't want
yeah that one's really close drinking
green tea I see yeah it calms me
chamomile isn't in your uh doesn't call
me I've done chamomile sometimes it
tastes a little funny on the aftertaste
you're drinking sparkling water with
some fruit in it what's funny about that
it's unsweetened it's healthy there's
nothing funny at all about it just have
the giggles I guess
you're kind of fake Lacroix a Barry
Lacroix wrong with this microphone
there's to it aren't there there's
another one hit you look like Steve with
those guns does it come this way
yeah nice is this where I'm going god I
hope so
oh we should probably get some episodes
in the bank now that I think of it I'll
be in New York for like two weeks and I
guess as well as okay so you are
I think it's oh [ __ ] you know what I
think it's the room that you passed in
the hall that's okay that's actually I
think I can do yeah because there's two
lifts one goes down to where the fire
was one goes up to the top of fish so my
point being we'll have to play a lot of
resonable zero in the next few weeks
here yeah we could probably double up
mm-hmm
I'll be working for one the weeks I'll
just be in our New York office or you
could go go check out you can go hang
out in New York and thinking we can do
it there that goes down I believe
all right you
open the map okay see when we go up cuz
it's one of the rooms around here we use
the crank EU we might have been right
the first time out in this hallway I
think down is where that's where the
fire is we don't this is the don't go up
here this is where you got the crane key
we're going we were right the first time
when he went into the so I want to get
down yeah you want to go back into that
ice room wait remember a long long time
ago there was that room where we're like
what are you even doing here there's
nothing to do that's the crane key room
I remember this room um yeah so wait I'm
just going back where I was into the
catwalk room so with the spider away
from the camera right now oh my god
you could not have made that more
nerve-wracking you ran right almost into
the light all right okay it's in here
it's one of these doors oh right there I
knew I was doing remember what we Hey
look who it is
Nosferatu he dropped something
is he alive
is up quick Alexia Alexia how I dispose
of insignificant bugs
said the spider to the fly how do you
wish to die
[Laughter]
[Music]
I should have brought something bigger
no no no you're not fighting to clarify
it's shoving it you're not just jump
down go grab that sorry fighter go grab
that jewel it nosferatu dropped and then
get that [ __ ] out of here head back
toward where you came
don't worry about the spider just dodge
it what yep this is not them how am i
doing good
run around so you could jump down onto
the ice yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then go over wherever that thing dropped
should be shining OB AHA I got it okay
now back to the cow just came from okay
and through the door I came from yep up
the s elevator I think that's the wrong
door Oh like the wrong exit you're on
the wrong side of the broken catwalk
can't I just go around I don't know
maybe no because the crane thing is
collapsed now that's not damn it you're
fine you're not kidding oh wow he missed
by a long shot
he's big but he's dumb
whoo okay I got me got me yeah a decent
amount of Health last time we checked
right yeah you got a bunch in these yeah
but I heard I have to like save a lot
else for Claire oh god no you're fine
are they not here anymore oh they turned
off sweet that was nice of them
considering I'm severely injured what do
you want caution definitely this is very
good
it's like Lacroix but they added real
juice to it slightly less healthy by two
grams of sugar but it's it's not like
fake stuff it's nature sure okay I'm
just nature's sugar son oh no cocaine
you probably have a bluer yeah you're
right near your item box blue though
yeah I guess so I was gonna say damn
you're selling yellow whatever you can
deal with yellow you have enough save
ribbons where you could probably save
again before we go back to you Claire
that wasn't a good fight wasn't a fight
at all not even answer I got hurt
baby Lincoln got hurt when at the play
that wasn't a fight
JFK yeah I said I don't know why it
those are both presidents that feel like
I'm necessary all right what am i doing
good question so I'm I've got some bugs
so we're gonna get Claire but I don't
know if you can come back to an item box
before like the fine the [ __ ] starts to
hit the fan all right if it does you
need you want the grenade launcher as
much Oh like I want the items on me now
I don't know that's what I'm wondering
that's a big deal yeah that's why I'm
saying I would save now because I know
you just saved like yeah 10 minutes ago
but you're saying I might have to redo
this if I thought you have more than
three ribbons right yeah I have like 40
I think at this point I don't care about
your final grade in the game it was it's
been an F for a while I'm kidding
why what was the which game was it was
heaving hurt your grade no I was yeah it
does did you not find that out in
Resident Evil was it res evil 3 where
you were pissed I mean our dignity might
take a blow but that's about it
I see my saving would hurt your grade
it's just like when you start to replay
the resonable games
yeah the grid felt fewer saves the but
higher grade you got ever you're taking
more of a risk oh I wonder if you should
bring that no no I don't never mind that
in here it's Magnum ammo anyway if I
remember correctly Plus claire has a
lockpick either way it won't matter all
right so uh oh can you do me a favor go
to the jewel that you picked up and they
can inspect it you might need to remove
that jewel much like you did with
Alfred's
[Music]
okay have a jewel alright so what do you
want to do with all this stuff I got two
jewels here they're both very nice
beautiful jewels do you want me to take
the grenade launcher good question is
she gonna need it
she's not going to but you do need to so
anything
so right now you want to leave it
honestly won't matter if I remember
correctly and based on YouTube comments
on our last episode it more matters what
Claire leaves in the box for Chris once
you become Claire cuz after that you
don't go back to an item box so right
now this isn't I don't I don't think you
need to be doing what you're doing
and what I just advise you to do so put
the shotgun away you won't don't want
that so she could use these this would
be good for her because I don't want to
leave stuff in the item box for Claire
yeah so I'll leave the submachine gun
because I'm not gonna use it
sorry I'm I should have read all of his
stuff I don't wanna risk anything at the
end of the game one Irby there's two in
here do I know how many herbs I have
yeah one
you got don't you blue one green three
three green to blue three three four
blue three green four four five blue
four green one in your inventory yes
so technically five blue five green
total okay so I do think yes you want to
bring all this grenade stuff on my plus
I would bring the submachine gun really
or the assault rifle one of the other
really yeah because I'm pretty sure when
it comes back to Chris you're pretty
much fighting bosses okay I have people
on people watching I don't this is all
like vague memory and YouTube tips from
our last oh they're gonna come after you
oh I don't at this point if you've been
watching the episode you know I don't
remember much of this how about that I
wish I saved after I did all this work
[Music]
it's my only regret maybe bring who
needs the jewels no you don't know no
sorry you don't need the jewels oh okay
then I think I'm good
sure if we did something wrong at least
we saved it yeah but this is we'll
figure out I don't think you're Claire
for crazy-long yeah alright so I'm going
to that mansion correct yes I'm
wondering if you should take more health
of Chris I mean I have one green and I'm
on caution so it's not great but I heard
that you need to have like two full
heels for Claire
okay yeah someone just say it in our
comments it's not a great time but as
Claire if I survive I can get to I can
put greens in the bin for him yeah at
this point you're just trying to make
life easier for the other character okay
all right so where is Claire isn't it
yeah that's them that's the lobby should
I like eat the screen so that I'm not on
caution anymore or is that not a big
deal I think you're good for now we're
gonna find out I can't believe I can get
the matter a damn fire extinguisher
I'm coming
easy hi Claire Claire alright
Chris
missed you so much Chris I'm so hungover
what we have to get out of here we have
to find Steve some [ __ ] so that means
Steve is still somewhere in this base
I'm sure of it
[Music]
Claire Oh see what's wrong
I think I think I've been poisoned
oh [ __ ] I didn't bring no medicine I'll
be right back no I didn't I ate it
that's where it wants me to go where was
that she could die
it's you're going back to the elevator
toward the fire extinguisher room so
door out of here
elevator on the left but yeah you'd have
to hurry this is like resonable one
oh it's timed it's not terrible it's
just number a resident one when you're
saving Rebecca Rebecca or yeah let's
begin for Becca that's who we're gonna
play in Reginald zero
wait so to the to the right hmm so we're
going to do the thing with Oh Lord that
scared me okay
you're going down to where the fire was
scheme loves reminding us about our
biggest mistake yeah I have like anxiety
I think I need a weapon we need guns so
that thing's gone so that's good do that
double or yeah
now down down yeah it's somewhere down
here
not totally sure where I'll I hope it's
not past that [ __ ] fire
alright [ __ ] knew it wait what are
you at like 25% bullet oh I was close is
that it sweet I mean I've been here a
lot go back that's it mm-hmm
people that fire is not gone out yet
like it just seems kind of cruel
[Music]
hurry up Claire's gonna die Chris I feel
like that's how they talk to each other
daddies I'll take care of you now hi
mater it's better than Steve thanks to
you all right just like a big brother
what'd you just do which is always
looking out for your little sister all
right like it's a very like platonic
line but it was delivered sexually and
it's let's do it all right you are
incubating for like eight years
she's been marinating what is that
bread we
giant snake Yoo Lian from the first game
I remember I thought that was her just
go
geez I'll be fine but Chris Steve go oh
my god I don't have to do [ __ ] no so I'm
clear now I'm Clara yep okay so let's
talk about this
Oh Lord should I heal yeah but no don't
use the first-aid spray why cuz you can
save that for Chris okay and you're on
dangerous OU's there might be something
in this room yes there is was hanging
around the table at least why don't we
look there's a red right here red and
the green so I can sort you happy you
didn't use that first date spray I
thought they were the same well no you
picked up the red and you combine it
with the green so now you can use the
green instead of the first day it's gray
but what's the difference between a red
and a green in a first-aid spray nothing
okay so I'm saying is that could have
used the first dates right technically
there's like arguing
all right so we're in agreement that I'm
gonna fully heal right now with a green
rather yeah okay I can't see right now I
can't there's palm trees yeah ficuses
it's super dark Florida ficus okay this
sounds like a safe room is there
anything toward the camera box wise I
knew it I think that's an ashtray and
some books that's all I need okay
there's something behind that bookshelf
should I move it mm-hmm probably more
magnum rounds I was like a shotgun thing
to put a shotgun there I I don't think
it won't permanently keep it if it's
anything like the last three and then
they will you'll be able to take it back
physics
what could this gun wrap be used for
this shotgun shaped hold for
Magnum renewal grenades I have so many
grenades
yeah probably too much too many I don't
think that's true in any case I don't
know where the [ __ ] I am okay here we go
give those to Chris through via the item
box and then [ __ ] it let's get out of
here you got it
handgun do you want those rounds I don't
what might as well I guess what I'm just
trying to remember I'm trying to think
if you should give those hanger I don't
think Chris is gonna have any use for
the handgun around so you can really
keep those I know you want healing items
for cleric what about more handgun
bullets or should I let him keep know
she was possible she might as well take
him he has a lot he has a set of changes
oh you could oh can you open the
duralumin case just to junior oh wait
where's your block pack you don't have
it I probably have it
give me magnum rounds probably I keep
saying that
give him to Chris second game okay
extinguisher all right what else let me
see how about the bow gun like he's not
gonna use that I only say this in the
sense that like you honestly a really
good on ammo it to the point where I
don't think you need to worry all right
but no it's health and I'm worried about
right now
I also get the shotgun back before you
forget sure but do I need more health I
have to green boy bees but you also want
Christian yeah leave the first day it's
bright for him oh and I can take another
can I you will be able to I don't need a
blue herb don't even bring three greens
I have to combine some greens I'd really
like to say I don't like this there's no
music no it's really misleading she
should take a shotgun and the shells
bring it with her yeah so I shouldn't
take these inky ribs because I was
thinking I'm gonna come across a box and
then I'll be able to save immediately
our sorry enough a safe room that maybe
doesn't have a box in it
cuz this is a box with no saver that was
my wine sauce
I made that decision you're not gonna be
all save I don't think really yes I
don't worry about the ribbons [ __ ] I'm
wonder if you combined herbs right now I
mean I can do it when I'm in trouble
yeah you're gonna need I don't want the
space right now
oh I need like another herb yeah oh geez
just in case he gonna have enough you'll
come across more but [ __ ] cuz if I cream
or the first day leave the first day for
him take one green you'll be fine if I
come across more I'm gonna have like a
shit-ton and he's gonna have none this
is good right here
I think oh you have a mixer right there
- that's good for him
he's got first aid mixed herb I'm
wondering if you should even banging one
more green no you need to you need
spaces this is good I think we're good
that's a mix of a blue and a green it's
not whatever let's go I need it how do
you do equip something do you think I'll
be fighting those giant jerks or do you
think it'll be mostly zoms if there's
anything like the snake it's probably
the tentacles that you fought earlier
so that'll that took a lot of ammo wait
didn't know wasn't hardened saved is a
long time to not save oh [ __ ] I can't
we could turn that light off if you want
no I just you could push those shelves I
do believe
[ __ ] Sorry Sorry it hooked me first of
all it scooped me let's move on what is
this what's what the green arrow going
down the hill that tentacle first I
think no you actually somehow
miraculously made it to the other side
without wasting any ammo on it I don't
think that was supposed to happen but
you could push this crate cart here so I
don't think you're backtracking through
there so right now we don't need to kill
a tentacle I can't move this track on
the other side here both @ub in tentacle
range I don't even know what's behind
there how do you know this I just there
like colored and animated to the point
where maybe not okay
or check okay whatever continue it's
really hard to see but I know I'm
hitting it so that awful noise
got it
okay this one moves sweet yeah it's
grenades it looks like I don't know if
you won't even want to pick those up I
did but I can't say no [ __ ] I don't I
can't use them
no don't you already have a ton I
wouldn't even worry about those yeah I
don't think there's any way that'll come
back to bite us
I've jinx things before though probably
plays shotgun out now oh and reload well
I don't want to use my shotgun on zoms I
only want to use them on those awful
things I'm just worried that a hunter is
gonna pop out I'm worried about that too
but if it happens I'll pull it out shut
up Chuck oh yeah that's the upgrade
oh no that's that you could put the
burst fire on if you wanted to but am i
doing most investigating just go to the
end of this corridor up those stairs
what a [ __ ] horrible camera thing
they just did to me yeah small stairs
first like definitely more weapons over
here can I get this sword how about this
cannon
Ashford family's most important secret
is kept at this lab as a safety
precaution I have installed a
self-destruct device the door locks will
be released to provide easy access to
escape routes by using the elevator that
directly connects to the hangar one
should be able to escape from the lab
easily
please remember that I've used the name
of my beautiful ancestor for the
activation code
glory to the ass Ashford's the name of
my beautiful ancestor alexander well
that's him Oh Veronica maybe no I'm
Veronica I don't know forget the
Ashford's
turn it alright is that gonna go down if
I go over there don't don't test it like
that what are you on yeah I guess run
around there what yeah I don't know how
else you'd get out
all right so whatever just drop pick it
up oh Jesus there's stuff inside the
this will just ruin everything
looks like you've to break this all
right how do i oh it's not insta-kill
can I drop it
yeah but hold on hon don't don't go up
and do it first run through to brick
drop it and then you know I mean like
trigger it so it drops and then as it's
coming back up get ready to run in
you'll have like an extra second I just
drop it right now just to see what it's
like sure first of all I don't know how
to do it is use yeah you have to be
standing on that path i pant so this I'm
saying you have like a couple seconds
one thing as it's going up to Jesus I'm
a little afraid I get stuck on that
don't don't
yeah run through the doorway so just so
it's a stranger other one yeah I don't
know it's better than running around the
catapult cannon again I don't know what
other option do you have running around
the catapult yeah I mean I guess that's
less distance it just feels like it's
less distance okay yeah that makes more
sense here we go yeah oh it's okay okay
okay
so you do have time as it goes up I
don't feel like I do and what's in there
I don't know
no no this is how you're supposed to do
you do yeah it doesn't look like it but
you're fine I'm gonna die I I think like
hopefully it gives you like more time if
it knows you're placing that and you do
it by hitting this and hitting like use
so now go yes I think you may be
standing on that light patches oh [ __ ]
that
that's how you die
you serious yeah I'll feel comfortable
at all
go go go
yeah see you're fine just run you might
be better oh okay we over thought that
but real oh you still have to get it I
wonder if it'll drop still yes it will
drop still this where's be the shadow
temple from zelda ocarina
you're doing great go oh my god I know
she grabs so slowly go back go back
nice okay sweet I don't know what's in
that room but I don't care yeah I mean I
could look what I don't know I think
you're set yeah I mean it's not a it
looks like bow gun arrows guys look like
bovine arrows let's say it's Boggan
arrows totally Boggan arrows so it's
bogus man alright so there's a door
there's that yeah and then there's
keycard thing next to it - you could use
the security guard right now just get
rid of it emergency door right but I go
use the card on the actual swiping thing
where's the Swiper to the right of it
I think just use the card you might need
to be facing the door struggle town here
no maybe go through the door I don't
know he won't let me I can't go upstairs
no wait go back go back go back past us
like before you came from there's a door
to your left you can use it on yeah wait
you have a weapon equipped right now
no maybe okay yes this room just looks
like death there's nothing good about
this room yeah we didn't check out those
there it's gonna release old - yeah
you're fine oh that guy's got it I would
run yes Brent because it looks like
they're gonna start swiping Oh Steve
this is the part that gets dicey what do
you hear dicey
like literally uh as you can imagine
those suits of armor I think friends
start attacking you you just have to
keep running and healing whenever you
need to heal so wait I'm not supposed to
attack no no no it's not a fight it's
escaped
you that crazy woman told me she was
good am i leaving the way I came in
yeah so I had to pass yeah she's
completely
oh oh he did oh my oh do they make him
into like I'm Nosferatu Oh nope nope
nope nope that seems okay get the [ __ ]
out of here
what okay yeah we heard you 180 she's
good-looking dude wait [ __ ] off
[Music]
yeah you might wanna do it run
okay heel heel heel heel heel heel you
can't let him hit you twice in a row
[Music]
oh [ __ ] maybe use one more green what am
I gonna do at that other one and two
greens are better together yeah that's
what I'm saying like right now you have
two heels with something okay well they
might as well combine them you just
can't get hit again I know but that's
the only way I can live okay maybe we
should hit me we might have taken more
help just like keep running and weaving
keep going keep going keep going keep
going
ah we'll just bring more health now that
we know we're doing we can we'll do fast
that's so stupid
did you actually dodge it when you
weaved or did that do anything I don't
know because it makes me go slower like
yeah this really isn't that bad
that's this far back that far back yeah
yeah you're right it's not that bad um
but yeah I would just keep that first
day it's bright in this case cuz we know
you need to do full heals full heals but
also yeah do this one again god damn
that guy is like not [ __ ] around
though like that's not about how much
damage I can do it don't matter how many
grenades I had how prepared you are I
think that's what people were talking
about holy moly that's why I've written
the comments like make sure you bring to
full yield I thought we had two full
Hills but I get I forget that two greens
doesn't make us whole greens no equal
you didn't want those grenades again oh
yeah I do I keep oh crap I forgot about
all the stuff I have to do it's not a
lot but like you didn't even need the
shotgun shotgun oh you're saying don't
put the shotgun on the thing because I
mean you can if you unless you want to
save time I just don't think you need
those grenades you have a lot already do
you think I mean it won't hurt to get
them you might as well
it's just so much effort to do this like
I said you have enough save ribbons
where you could do all this and then
save again and then go fight him or run
or whatever it is I can leave this room
no no I'm saying when you're done with
getting the grenades and the shotgun
thing and reorganizing oh that's like
it's not possible to save at this point
oh yeah I just realized they give you a
checkpoint right there yeah oh but
there's no save right okay
I see what you're saying yeah it's
annoying and like thank God they give me
this box but even with the box I like
you can't I can't take any man oh yeah
also when Steve was hitting you I know
this seems obvious but like as soon as
he hits you he'll because then you're
when you get hurt enough you're gonna
start limping and he's gonna have more
you're gonna have less space between you
if that makes sense like when you get
heard enough you start limping and
that's gonna slow you down so heal as
soon as you can f you you did I'm you're
saying remember to do so again so let me
ask you this how should I heal right now
do a full heal because then I won't have
a red and green combo oh yeah you could
so I could do a green and a green is
what I'm trying to say no no well that
is that even different than do it two
separate greens I was thinking I could
do a green and a green and then do one
more green to get to fine okay that was
my thought
saving one green okay as opposed to a
red and a green which I can take and
I'll also take that spray and that's two
full heals
works for me does that make sense mm-hmm
I don't know if that's right it's just
where I'm at
so I'll take one more Green is what I'm
saying
yes and I'll eat it right now and then
I'll have to full heels and the only
other thing I can think of is I'll take
another [ __ ] one if you want
but then Chris is gonna have nothing
he's gonna have nothing he's not gonna
have a lot yeah you know it's concerning
so I will say Chris there's more time
with Chris and you get more items but I
mean I'm in danger here like she's not
well well yeah I would still use another
green because he's gonna kill you in one
hit if you don't I could take another
one I'm just like I don't know yeah yeah
I think you have to otherwise he's gonna
kill you in one hit no no don't you
ready yeah just do what I'm gonna
combine these okay and then I eat this
yeah see so they only use three and then
I could take another two if you think I
need it just in case yeah well then he
doesn't get them right it's like I mean
yeah technically you have all that you
need right now I think I think he hits
you twice you were close I don't
yeah what's how much
that's my last green if I take that he
gets nothing from me okay then let's
just go with this you don't even need
the shotgun thank you oh wait there's
two but still I'm gonna take do you
think I don't need it I'm gonna take the
shotgun oh you have a green right there
oh right I could take that oh I have a
couple take one it will even matter I
don't know one more I don't know
it won't cuz he got you down actually
yeah yeah so he brought you from green
to red in one hit so then theoretically
you would have to be at Green before he
hits you each time right cuz if you're
at caution and he hits you you're just
gonna die right
I like honestly okay so I'm pretty sure
there's no [ __ ] thing like this with
Chris so you need to worry more about
health with Claire right Chris you have
enough ammo now that I know what twists
expect maybe I'll get hit less so maybe
I only need two full heels now okay what
do you think sure um also what again as
with last time do the 180 turn like you
did because otherwise you have to circle
around and inhale die yeah and you
should we get skipped the cutscene this
time can we skip cutscenes in this game
yeah that's such bad if any did you get
the shotgun back I kept the shotgun it's
on you Claire the reason I did is
because I was close to running out of
bullets yes nice
I got hit less that time yeah that's
actually true you might be matters but
you might be higher Optifine
I'm not moving that that was regular
grenades we have enough grenades we
decided and you won't even get back to a
safe box with Claire right I mean you
could go back to the one you just came
from he wanted to give him those
grenades but you'd have to go past the
tentacles
stay down oh my god I have to do the
[ __ ] crystal ball again but now we
know it's not as bad as we were
imagining it it can be does it even
smash on this one no it's only after I
get this pamphlet I'm going in here what
do you got for me Logan
arrows the other ones Bhavana nobody
wants this [ __ ] I can waste my time all
right just get that out of my system you
know not getting that angle right I'm
going to turn this handle like a little
ball
all right I feel fine
I feel fine I think I do it too early
little bit scares the [ __ ] out of me
it's not the way I want to go okay do
you want to go upstairs cuz I haven't
done that yet sure that'd be funny if
there was first-aid spray or something
god
oh this worries me what is it [ __ ] is up
here Oh Oh what is that it is at the top
of the insect wall I don't know well
there's three doors
I have dragonfly wings you both I think
Chris comes back here though okay so
this is a Chris thing I mean it could be
either I guess I bet you this is where
the final boss fight is maybe all right
so we're gonna try this again
yeah I don't like anything about it like
why is he so good at killing you know
Amy in like I mean I'm just practicing
okay I think I got it
I'm gonna run but I feel like he's gonna
kill me Steve Oh
Claire I can't skip it
I can't do it who did this to you that
crazy woman told me she was gonna
perform the same experiment on me that
she did on her own father she's
completely insane Oh skip this touch pad
I tried it oh sorry or any other button
[Music]
[Music]
worse oh alright
so back up and run like hell
mica mica mica mica mica
[Music]
I'm gonna do my best but he's definitely
gonna hit me yeah I think he has to
[Music]
nice Lucy you only meant to orange
that's good student brought the other
green I mean I need to do it yeah I
think you got it as long as you yeah
you're gonna get hit once more yes nice
you still have like a ninja turtle just
stand there Claire yeah I mean I don't
feel
[Applause]
[Music]
and that was her dying noise I blame her
she just stood there
[Music]
it's gonna cut the tentacles because he
loved me
[Applause]
wait remember me that's who's gonna be
Nikki poo
[Music]
yeah
Steve you've got to hang in there I mean
he's dead lady your brother
kept his promise I'm sorry I cannot what
what are you saying
I'm glad that I met you I I love you
Claire if he was alive for a little bit
longer I bet you you would have heard
her say thanks thanks for that
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
just hiding at last I found you Alexia
come with me
you're responsible for the creation of
the team Aronica virus and now the only
existing sample is in your body
hmm I want it now what does he want her
body way reach out the sample of the
virus oh I see really nice oh you need
her door
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
she's Nikki
and snaky
Wow they left one nipple nice
she impressed her
[Music]
[Music]
you're coming with me what if the boss
fight is just them fighting wow that was
cool
[Music]
Wesker
[Music]
um Chris since you're one of my best men
I'll let you oh wait
weapons you have nothing yo I took the
grenade launcher just in case oh nice
okay cool
but I don't have any heels I don't
[ __ ]
I can't do this
I use this green herb probably yeah we
didn't think about this yeah we did and
I said I just said like I don't I don't
see what else we could what he would
need more herbs just don't learn just
true I just get away from her though get
away from her
yeah I did say get away from her I know
I think you got a checkpoint if it was
anything like with clarity I didn't know
she was gonna explode my brain hmm she
was on fire like what if I get you skip
these I'm trying known I do like why
don't they like I found you Alexia come
with me
hold the button
the existing sample is in your body give
me no gimme gimme some eat you just want
to get her brooch thing right now also
wait I don't want to fight her
no no you have to fight her because she
has to go down and run so firing faster
I want to run away and then shoot and
shoot her a few times
mm-hmm okay I can do this oh my god such
a sweet that was just that you can't
skip the full motion stuff oh I got it
[Music]
wait oh [ __ ] she trapped you with the
fire she sure did
what should I do I can eat this and I
couldn't yeah go to the yellow rounds
how combine what are the yellow rounds
acid
[Music]
I'm like stuck how long does fire last
[Music]
yeah god damn run the other way this
time okay
I'm learning mm-hmm thank God for
checkpoints - oh wait sorry I forgot
sorry I got it
[ __ ] whoo light her up
oh man that didn't why do you keep
running into these back corners stop
that alright you've recovered messed up
god this boss fight sucks for these
controls oh well didn't wash our cousin
am i dead
true you said it not me this is a mean
one
oh you sir press the right side of the
touchpad I press both of them that's
what I
[Music]
do the gray rounds again that just I
don't know why those yellow ones don't
seem like they're racial but oh shoot
that's shooting a lot
got me with a little bit of acid there
[Music]
no don't
[Music]
[ __ ] you idiot go goddamnit
so what he does is he like brushes I
should get it and then you like sits
there for a [ __ ] second switch to the
red ones because those gray ones why
does it always shoot four at a time
what what is red thing over there right
now I can't do when I'm equipping it
right
[Music]
hover over the gray ones quick just to
see what they say
just grenade okay okay well we're fine
what do you mean we're fine just kill
her
[Music]
fire doesn't affect her I mean it's
gonna hurt her just not knocking back I
guess either one works this is the worst
fight it's kind of cool actually
compared to a lot of other stuff that
you're doing I'm right yeah that wasn't
your fault entirely you ran into the
corner oh nice whoo
[Music]
this is no time to brush fire wait nice
ok run and grab the brooch we're on the
stairs see
oh right there there there there there
there there there see here I don't know
just get it and get the [ __ ] outta I'm
stressed out I head up the stairs going
up the stairs oh wait oh she's down okay
wait okay yeah so now you need the three
jewels where's the nearest item box you
need to go back oh we could save now -
yes sweet umm map yeah so that door you
still can't use right oh you're very
close yeah what's that noise
no that's fine oh that's just to let you
know that you're fighting her again
later okay which is idiot okay I hope
have enough grenades I know we were like
I got lots but like I just used like 9
you have a lot more no I don't I took
them all with me but you have my
submachine guns assault rifle sure it's
the game would be infinitely easier with
a magnum yeah but go on
alright let's load up
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna take these two greens and I'm
gonna combine them are you listening to
me
yes taking the two greens and combine
them okay so we've said yes it is wait I
just repeated vaguely what it sound
that's fine
I just want you to understand that I'm
like okay you have explosive powder at
all I think so yeah just make a bunch of
explosive arrows too but then I have to
bring the explosive thing like no no no
no you don't do that now I just want to
see if you have explosive sorry
explosive powder powder I think so and
you could save in here right yes
gunpowder arrow oh I did it before
bogan oh wait go back up oh I guess I
don't go back sorry go back up I only
have 10 explosive arrows those those
still might be worth bringing I'm
telling you I'm okay Mary I'm reading
[ __ ] right now that says okay don't
that's fine don't know now right now I
meant for the final boss I know I wasn't
listening you okay where should I bring
anything else
now you'll know
Oh God it's getting really stressful I
am gonna heal that seems worth it
[Music]
okay so I saved put these inky ribs away
what health of Ma'at Myatt caution is
friend yellow cautions or one green
should fix me up that's not a lot of
heals you'll get more you're not boss
isn't yet but I need all these you need
the jewels don't worry I wouldn't worry
about that last green herb I'm gonna
heal up somebody did
I mean I don't think you need to combine
them like I don't need it at all
no Oh your breath yeah yeah no you're
fine without it I think yeah it doesn't
it doesn't matter right am I about to go
into right now do I need like a handgun
cuz I only brought like the toppest
creme de la creme here yeah don't yeah
bring the handgun so I'm not doing a
final boss fight not yet and I will go
back to a boss before I do it or box yes
I don't feel like you sounded very
secure about the only reason I'm really
making sure that we're doing the right
thing is because the ends of the older
residents tend to stop giving you too
much leeway although you're getting
checkpoints here so where the hell is
the handgun oh my god is Claire oh it's
in here it was way down her handgun was
different it's right there
enhancing
and I'll equip this alright I think
we're in a good spot so am I going back
to the the mansion and then upstairs
yeah the picture frame with those three
jewel holes in it no I don't have a
shotgun do I need a shotgun no Claire
has it anyway I [ __ ] that one up yeah
I told you not to take it I know but I
think you're fine without it you might
want the handgun during the final yeah
lady was gross it's kind of a cooler
boss fight than normal though the for
the flames at least the flame yeah
although I don't think I mean nowadays I
don't think it's great to have that with
tank controls so that's the photo with
the things there's weird holes open
that's not what I meant to do sorry
and keep hitting the button oh my god
did you wait what's up here it's where
you got the combat knife right I don't
know if there's like a door up here
anything it's like the weirdest hallway
ever okay
the sinister-looking Doric yes chef how
did Dom bees get in here you know
oh it's one of those take a few more I
have this thing that I also brought yeah
it's always Tamil at this point let's go
through this door might as well well
then I would waste the two shots did you
are you sure you hit him he's pretty far
away I didn't okay
yeah just see what that door is all
about I'm gonna see what this door is
all about
oh I saw something shiny it's a book the
shiniest book after long years of
research inheritance elements succeeded
in manipulating absolute value of
intelligence artificially sampled the
gene of our ancestor and put in like an
egg
Boyet higher intelligence but not enough
for him to be considered a genius
the girl had unmatched intelligence so
the guy was big dum-dum I already
determined their names okay so some lor
oh that's an Arab take them all this
[ __ ] I will also you can reload right
here just make sure weird some kind of
control panel okay upstairs or
downstairs up no way no go down first
let me check your shotgun shells down
there to see them I see them actually
don't pick those up
why so they don't have a shotgun
a wing I can't open this with my hands I
have four interesting very interesting
okay no okay wait no I don't have a
shotgun
I know but okay you got that sterile
room key yeah go back up I guess and
then there's something we missed up
there okay
wait
there's that upstairs yeah is that what
it is it looks like a door though didn't
it yes yeah I guess go check out out
there
[Music]
oh wait
[Music]
oh you're back here okay you don't want
to be here I mean that's where you're
going eventually with the Dragonfly
stuff right but I don't have it yet I
think there's something missing in here
though go down one more time I so make
sure you're getting everything
I guess so
then there's the shotgun okay well yeah
I guess
I mean maybe but I don't see anything
[Music]
there you know just call here okay
zombies back down the hall I'm not back
down the hall books down the hall right
here there's a bee
a Jew camera-shy skills I can't see he's
too fast oh my god did you see how fast
that was you backed up oh I'm on caution
but come on wait it's another one he got
caught on the corner if you don't have
to kill him I guess
I'm running out of bullets
[ __ ] I got hurt that sucks where am I I
know this is unprecedented but I might
sprint to the bathroom while you explore
this hallway because I want to finish
the game on this episode and we're close
okay I'm gonna go fast can i play this
oh yeah yeah you know what to stop I'm
just saying I'll be right back
bye okay never play this by myself
before it's kind of scary God if I die
without him he comes back I died I'll
never hear the end of it
Oh a safe room useless books portrait of
a beautiful woman
Oh sterile room alright don't it there's
no box in here though so I gotta be a
little careful like naturally I want to
[ __ ] save and I assume that I can
it's just that I'll have these pucks on
me and then I won't have as much
inventory but I think it's better to
save than not save at this point and I
don't give a [ __ ] about my rating oh
[ __ ] that's my last spot though
you know what's funny is I could save
three times so that I would have that
spot Mike would love that if I did that
it was a quick bead I pooped no just
kidding
so I have some good news I did not die
sweet um you say you brought coffee
yeah sure kind of getting 7:00 p.m.
Pacific here what was the good news
what'd you find oh you just did my ink
ribbons Oh like we needed those I didn't
die you and I found this sterile room
key mmm
but now oh and two first and a
first-date price we and a first aid
spray but now I have these ink ribbons
and I am completely full which is a
bummer but I'm on caution so I'll sing
about eating this herb okay sweet I came
back and the inventory just full hey I
could have been dead ya know I'm not
complaining it's a good thing I mean
it's full with useful stuff sorry oh my
god
look at all these [ __ ] herbs what's
in this green room oh [ __ ] I know where
you are this is back in the this is
Alexios bedroom hallway and Alfred's now
I'm not taking that green herb because I
might need to pick something up to like
get through with them something here
mm-hmm
oh Lord you probably need to do that
record stuff again
yeah what do you mean
oh geez not sure I'm doing I have no
idea either
[Music]
go right on through or something
so I'm on the other side of the wall
oh I remember what you have to do and um
no no okay this is annoying
remember the tiger yes
had a blue and red eye yes but because
the power was on each time you took one
out it would rotate you need to turn the
power off in the save room and then go
get the blue and red jewels bring them
up here it's not as bad as it sounds use
at the backtrack a little bit and since
you're going back
what is your inventory look like it's
full its full except for so you're
coming back up here so that's good news
yeah and you can get rid of the wing and
the ribbons yeah and you could save yes
okay so let's go back out of the mansion
all right so I'm leaving the mansion yes
was it this one [ __ ] I get so good no
down the long hallway this one alright
yeah I remember where I am now I I also
[Music]
and I can't like accidentally trigger
the ending right like I know it's it's
pretty much that area where you
suspected the last boss boy would be
alright so going into this box no yeah I
mean this is the room you got turn the
power off in anyway I forgot where the
tiger was though actually no I didn't
should be still showing up the map did I
already turn off the power no you do it
in this room right here that lever over
so what about the sterile room gee
what's that about I don't know oh that
you know
and do I have enough weapons
[Music]
for now the sterile room key I believe
is the double door from the mansion
lobby
should I take something no I'm fine
right I'm gonna keep it because I might
need it okay but like what about your
handgun rounds no oh you got there sorry
yeah but I only have 25 one green herbs
in case no no this hanging around
through there remember those should I
take some bow I could take a bow II know
that'll take up takes up one oh the ball
gone by itself you have 64 yeah sure if
you're gonna do that you might as well
not even bring the handgun I mean I only
have eight bullets that's like enough
for one zombie that's why I say that you
know I mean mm-hmm
I feel like that's enough for like four
zombies
all right and then one greener is what
we discussed and that's it yeah
do I need a thing to do this oh sorry go
yeah right there that thing that scared
me I was like where the [ __ ] is the
valve you know it would suck if you ran
into a hunter without the shotgun yes
just you would dodge it this perfect
[Music]
okay where was the tiger at oh it's that
yellow thing the end of that Hall but
that's a lock oh [ __ ] how am I gonna get
there
oh so the sterile room key I'm fairly
certain to opens this red door at the
end of the hallway oh that makes sense
that would be great I hope I mean I
[ __ ] hope so too
otherwise it just it's as simple as
going back to that very dark it's scary
it's a dark and scary you're facing the
wall right now of course
oh okay so yes I believe the stale room
key will open the double door from the
mansion lobby that's the one that's been
locked all this time so the key allows
you to before this you would not have
been able to even interact with the
tiger if the power was off because that
doors locked but now the other sterile
room key that allows you to loop back
behind it but how do I leap back so I go
to the mansion again bossfight is it
here yeah I hope that's it why is that
called the sterile Tigers mr. sweet
freed up a spot go get those [ __ ]
spot I wonder if you want our background
when you go upstairs is that oh it won't
matter because the mansion is separate
is there anything in here you didn't get
earlier I mean if I if there is I can't
see all right now you can get both of
those you see kind of yeah yeah yep no
oh my god I can't oh yeah yours is bad
the glare yeah you should tell the see
because I want you fighting the boss
we're just glad you're gonna be that
dark when I fight the boss it's gonna be
dark or right now you got those all
right we are on our way to the boss I
should save ya oh yeah this is the last
chance you get to save so you also need
to stock up or no it's not sorry you get
the yes okay
you should save yes okay but I'm going
what about the wings that's what you're
going using the music box stuff for to
get that and then go back and fight the
boss wait does that mean I'm not getting
those two green herbs no you're going
back up there right now
after you save okay in turn I don't know
if you want the power back I didn't
really don't think it matters because
the mansion's power is separate
I want to turn it on just we can see all
right so do I need the wings and then I
combine them or something
take the wings
yeah combine the wings take those some
help I don't need this bow gun anymore
well no take this alright one oh no it
takes up two submachine guns for sure
take those I mean I'm not gonna be able
to take any like grenades take them
regular grenades why take those in
addition because you're gonna fight
stuff but you want blue orbs - what do
you mean why why the grenade rounds that
are blue and not the red ones cuz the
red ones barely did anything - Alexia
but that's because she was a fire
monster and you don't fight fire with
fire don't you play pokemon okay I
forgot you beat her fire form okay so
now I would get rid of that green herb
you need oh there's another save box we
don't need to worry about this stuff yet
don't I combine no those are for that
let's just go back up to the mansion you
there's another save box member upstairs
way back in the game there's like a say
box up in the tower with the Carousel
the creepy carousel yes let's just go
back up there alright sorry
so you're saying do I need to save again
though are you safe that's time to save
sure okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna get rid of those guns he's not
gonna use them if anything does attack
me is there possibility to get anything
while attacking right
it's possible yeah why wouldn't you use
the guns because I want those for the
boss and there's a save box later oh
right so I'm gonna use maybe just bring
the bow gun again for between here in
the next day yes you do have ten
explosive arrows which could be useful
later
so I once we get them it's two slots no
cuz if you put the explosive arrows load
them into the Boggan that's the bow gun
with ten exposed roses one slot oh I see
we're saying okay we can talk about that
let's talk about that when we get there
okay all right so I need to save for the
last time you should I mean you should
bring them wet bow you got the boat
and I think this is why I save but you
have 21 honks anyway so okay seriously
fix this monitor or turn that light off
if you need to so you're not it's not
this dark when you can you see better
now yeah okay it's just the glare is
like really bad yeah
if I am if I use too many pucks how come
I have so many left riddle me this I
don't know like I feel like I do a good
job I'm not saying you do a bad job
they're saying the game thinks you do so
I'm not turning this power back on I
don't think so okay
[Music]
[ __ ] wait would that affect the music
boxes do you think no I don't think the
power in the mansion matters you should
just turn it on in case so you don't the
backtrack if it doesn't hurt ya cuz you
already got the tiger eyes what song
does that remind me of I of the Rhino no
I'm close though
[Music]
[Music]
okay that's little Bowie got I'm briefly
saved so it's not a bunch of stress
going upstairs
going through this door it's so weird
that this very important door led to a
place I've been before
just run barely even hitting it I
[ __ ] was trying just you might as
well go where am i going past him why
did they come back if you kill them
right there's so many yeah just wait
hopefully this isn't locked Duke
nice nice I do too far [ __ ] on
caution now stupid goddamn damn you're
fine on how I feel like you'll find me
more right now what am I even doing in
here putting the blue jewel
[Music]
yeah pisses me off
dumb [ __ ] is the point of closing it
first yeah take it oh yeah yeah cuz
you're gonna open the blue one and put
that in so the ladder comes down then
you go up the tower this was like 10
episodes ago maybe I do remember this
ordeal but I don't remember being so
dumb there's I missed them let me just
save your health I am so there's a lot
of Hell right on the other end not evil
oh okay yeah I thought you did that out
of panic no just get those and get out
of here I don't know if I can pick two
up and get through that door without him
eating me again just do it does that
mean just do it just get them get him
ago quick nice oh right Mary you're both
aware of what's about to happen get it
anyway you Mary I don't know if I can
take this Oh
oh my god damn it that's disappointing
no I don't want you foul it's fun that
was funny
okay whew you just flaunted it in that
guy's face thank God they don't know
doors work is this the longest season of
knievel ever or no three was very long
wasn't it three or did we just feel like
an eternity felt like it was long
because I spent a whole episode once
dying that was funny
[Music]
in res evil 5 there was a point where
our friendship was actually tested by
during the boss fight yeah yeah I put
the controller that was back in my
stubborn days I've gotten better burned
days first of all that was like a couple
months ago resin will fly once you have
a couple wrong that much as a human
being really do you want I I am nowhere
near that bad anymore that was come on
let me look up when that was it snarky
man snark and stubbornness are different
Wu more greens I take them I would take
the handgun rounds oh I'm not gonna use
them wait no hold on before you do this
get the key item up here there's
something up here god it is dark is it
it keys it's right there and then it
kind of might as well be dragonfly
object Wow mind the wing resident oh
nice I see what you did thank you okay
we started resin evil seven last
November uh-huh we started that long ago
okay Knievel's code veronica has been a
long one let me look this up well so we
used to do I don't know if you remember
this we used to do two episodes a week
and now we only do one Episode a week oh
right yeah because of time
negligence wait
okay so that if you remember that's the
key to the final boss pretty much right
there what are you looking at what I'm
gonna get this help
there's handgun it on sale well you want
those I'm not gonna unless I'm gonna
fight the boss with handgun rounds but
what about their zombies on the way out
you're gonna have these amazing boat
that's not gonna work that barely did
anything I was just gonna run you're
gonna get hurt though yeah did I do it
is this it did I get everything
wait what's behind there did you do
everything behind there I go back at you
were just behind that for a second were
you that's where I came from
oh there's hanging around the table okay
so I do want these save box up here
there's no box that I'm aware of
oh my go back oh that's where you came
from
gotcha so I remember being up here this
is the other side so I think up the
other ladders a safe box if you that way
I mean you could I'm trying to think if
you'll trigger anything so I have to put
all that effort and doing this stupid
thing again I can't get it you can't no
okay then let's go back to save box yes
like I have to uh-huh and unfortunately
I didn't bring like the right [ __ ]
guns so I can either shoot it with a
[ __ ] grenade launcher or I can do
more bow guns but I'm gonna get hit
again this was stupid
dude bogan I don't know why they were
missing so often maybe just where am I
going
let's figure this out yeah yes I have to
go through like 20 zombies you got
enough arrows to take care of him if you
hit him
what's this pink is that a safe room the
yeah I guess so you were in there that
was the room you went in when I was gone
you would know more than me I wouldn't
for it though I think pink is always
room is there a box no it's just a
typewriter yes
goddamnit oh nice holy [ __ ] he didn't
get you you stop his face I don't think
you got hurt at all
what am i doing well you're fine I don't
think that really hurts you that much
well [ __ ] light him up the cavalry
all right what are we doing just reset
it yeah go through the door it doesn't
matter you wouldn't have used those
arrows in any way I didn't really waste
anything
oh my god I could have been more like
unprepared for this area didn't shoot
them there's no way they started on the
other side of the hallway I think so as
long as you reset them your fellow
marine that always hurry okay you're
good yeah whatever
and why am I going go through this
hallway again I would go to say box I
just used two green herbs I feel really
bad I didn't tell you I feel like I have
to tell you I'm trying to member how you
get back
okay now we're loading up for the final
boss fight pretty much I hope so
I'm gonna save again I'm a little
concerned that I'd like eaten so much
like green herbs I don't have any for
this final boss buy it you know don't
you have a whole first day it's preto I
have a first-aid spray oh and you need
poison blue herbs so just start
combining I do have a lot so this boss
fight is not like this Steve Feng you're
definitely gonna take damage for sure
okay but it's not like inevitable so
save these green herbs for blue orbs to
combine okay that one just do those now
okay so you want me to have two green
and blues yeah okay
actually wait wait wait sorry before you
do that this is good right here I would
say before you these items in case we
screw anything up well you needed will
blue and green anyway okay you do all
this stuff yeah but I'd rather redo it
then completely [ __ ] yourself over oh
you could do multiple saves but yeah I'm
there see what you're saying yeah we
haven't done the boss but yet so like if
we die we'll probably have to reevaluate
anyway I understand
I was looking up how long this was the
boss no the rest of the season so I've
seen what the longest one was just go to
youtube stupid computer alright yeah
this will be our 96th episode 97
including our intro on so season 1 was
ok well thatís ODEs alright here's what
I got I got a blue and green which will
save me when I get poisoned mm-hmm a
full heal in a not full heal submachine
gun so healing was a grenade launcher
with a [ __ ] ton of grenades that's it I
would honestly give any other green
herbs in your inventory yes I would
honestly Rick almost recommend getting
rid of that double green and doing a
blue green there okay cuz he already
gonna fall you're gonna get rid of the
Dragonfly and then that's it this is
like all I can breathe
yeah but weapon was so there are gonna
be many enemies that are gonna be
shooting or you can so it's not like
you're only shooting the boss right but
maybe for healing things I don't even
know if you need that double green
and like I said the crossbow with the 10
explosive rounds which should only take
up one space you might need some shuffle
stuff around first
yeah there's those alone and can help
against the boss yes yeah you have one
more space might as well no no I wrote
something together
again we might have to reevaluate this
but right now this seems good
oh [ __ ] I'm hurt oh yeah I'm so [ __ ]
stupid
that's right let's talk about this you
have any single green herbs I should
have one I think that resin evil one was
twelve episodes res equal to was eight
navel three ooh
res me well three was fourteen four was
four was sixteen
that's the longest so far you may ask
you this where am I going right now I'm
going back to that room with all those
zombies that's a good question it's the
door that you unlock that gets you past
the first tentacle you unlocked it from
one side I'm trying to how you got there
oh you are going past those dudes again
right but you have the Uzis now I have
the door there's a door that gets me
through it that's what I'm saying I
don't remember how you got there I think
you have to go back toward the I mean
your map might be uh so it turns out res
evil for was the longest so far that was
what I really needed to do here it was
kill these zombies and I didn't so if I
made you pay attention
I am I either go up there and I deal
with those zombies or I go this this way
and I have no no to the tiger doesn't it
yeah this goes to the tiger I know what
you're thinking it's connected
no you gotta go upstairs
definitely and then yeah you go into the
I you're gonna fight those a couple of
zombies again in that hallway that you
just came through but you got the Uzis
you can just waste them
but those these are like for a boss I
don't know I mean you're only it's only
gonna get a little percentage oh wait is
it on what's up the stairs on the other
side you remember I think you're going
the right way right now okay it's yeah I
just waste them nice
your friend okay sweet cool you're
probably at like 85 percent still 86
sweet I thought that's at 36% okay going
to the world is right right yes if you
could yuccas do do it oh man
that's a dumb camera we're know this is
the wrong way bring the map up it's not
in here is it is it where I said what do
you mean where do you say downstairs in
the double doors no it's those stairs
right there oh no it's it's in the door
we need to kill those yeah you did they
were in the way you're here they were in
the way all right they're not these
small stairs and through there oh yeah
this is our longest season so far
just for the record it feels like it but
not in a horrible way
no like I'm not mad about it I think
three was the longest for me mentally I
was just so tired of like oh [ __ ]
there's [ __ ] zombies in here
no no tentacles but the submachine gun
again is probably still your best bet
you got grenades for the boss explosive
rounds for the boss
so just oh no you already killed it
you're fine you don't need to yeah yeah
oh [ __ ]
Claire is that you Claire no hey Steve
with you he did you [ __ ] dad keep it
together
yeah it was Steve every single resonable
game Oh No oh okay no you can use the
use the Dragonfly and then come back
okay I believe that will work yes yes
yes I knew yeah yeah we are getting
close or is it it's not gonna trigger
the boss yeah it's up those stairs
you're sure yes well no but we'll find
out
[Music]
yeah don't ya what don't you know no
yeah do that but I yeah sorry I'm
getting antsy okay I'll go get go
goodbye know what ever was
yeah you have guns equipped right now
just so I know yeah I have the double
ones that uses I'm beating these games
again vicariously through you maybe well
5ix I was insects yes even though you
didn't really need my help for this
season I was just good moral support
when you and I used to be way more
negative I will pull up yeah when you
went to the bathroom oh wait sorry check
it I was like it's so lonely about like
having another person here it's carriers
did you talk [ __ ] about me no it's like
the first thing I do and you leave what
a piece of [ __ ] something seems to be
caught inside I think if you keep
pressing what you were just pressing
enough joking let's make it funny how
many times you do the same thing damn it
still negative no I'm not or just
sarcastic look at the pages yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
what security lock pass the dragonfly
maybe okay here we go hopefully there's
a checkpoint of some sort that would be
nice yeah and we haven't done a crazy
[Music]
are you serious
I think I have to kill these things this
is a dead end where am I going
looks like that little thing at the end
yeah but what is this no idea oh you're
killing me is that a mirror you shrink
two dudes nice thank you
wait [ __ ] was there anything back there
worthwhile I mean yeah at this point
just [ __ ] oh it was a greener but I
think you are pal
yeah no way I do have one [ __ ]
do you I don't know you don't yeah I
just use it let us hope we prepared Papa
bless oh no oh it's his ancestor
Veronica oh that makes sense
hence the name again got it
[Music]
verification progress you're now
verified okay okay so she's safe
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god what am i doing just exit the
back the way you came I I'm with you but
nice good job sweet I hate how these
clocks keep going and during the door I
think that's rude
where am I going I think this is it
you're about to find out how snake-like
I can be
what are we gonna do shoot it
oh okay turn the key clockwise
simultaneously on three
[Music]
oh is it a spider
I don't like skin stuff why are they
waiting three seconds
that's like a weird thing to like wait
to three on I mean yeah you're supposed
to synchronize it otherwise it'll [ __ ]
up but yeah three seconds is a long time
in this situation I would to go on to
start shooting with it was easy this is
no time to argue Chris I've always found
you attractive [ __ ] her up
[Music]
oh shoot er sorry you use the aziz why
just use them trust me you're sorry I'll
explain during next nice okay see that's
all you need now get the grenade
launcher got it sorry I didn't mean to
be no it's fine I just didn't understand
I'd I would not have known either this
is when it gets hard so you want to keep
moving after you shoot and [ __ ]
all right there's a lot of evolution
happening
see if there's gonna be bugs flying at
you okay if they get overwhelming I
would use these to take them out but
other than that I would use right with
regular grenade rounds should I use the
acid ones now that are already in there
yeah sure the counts down like
[Music]
oh yeah the thing movie yeah that's
right now you're maybe maybe you though
there's a lot going on here not getting
hurt that much it's just I think it's
okay let me warranty this fight will get
seem overwhelming but it's not as bad as
my checkup it 'nor know cuz they're
gonna start swarming you okay so aim
down at them I would say I think you
have to or just like shoot them and then
shoot her
alright alright there you go I need to
kill you might be
I don't think I have enough heels for
this yeah you
he had just moved those [ __ ] bugs
that make us annoying
finish your run
goddamnit I'm so slow dude you might be
on bread right now I mean sorry I like
feel a little stressed out here I need
to eat that yeah it might just be better
to keep moving and then just keep like
the bugs are gonna [ __ ] bug I haven't
even hit her yeah but I would use the
regular grenades they shoot 5 and the
asset ones just don't seem to be it
could be wrong but then you also have
explosive arrows which are gonna be
useful okay you got it like you've got
the movement I don't think you're
reaching her you can heal oh [ __ ] I
don't know okay now I have two enemy two
no I think you're good just obviously be
careful there's just so much going on
yeah like I said it's just yeah just
unloaded on much choice like you didn't
do that bad that was that was good like
I said it's just overwhelming there was
so much going on but you were it okay so
I think we learned that it might not
even be worth seeing the bugs although I
will say right at the beginning of the
fight we missed out on a few seconds
where you could just record so I don't
have to change my uh no I don't think so
here and I don't think I need to know
but like I said at the beginning of the
fight there was a few seconds where we
could have unloaded on her so say that
again at the beginning right after the
second after the cutscene when she falls
and transforms there's like a few
seconds where she doesn't attack you
that's normally when you would unload
the Magnum no no not that part all I'll
show you when we get to it can I do this
fight without the Magnum yes you can you
have a lot of grenades and like I said
it just feels overwhelming like even
with the Magnum you would still be
getting overwhelmed by the bugs I feel
like I need more health if it comes to
that we can go get it
I think you're fine
you also have the explosive arrows
there's a [ __ ] green herb right there
did you see that that's what I said
earlier but earful aren't you wait wait
where's the green herb it was next why
didn't you get it because I had already
panicked and moved on okay
well we'll keep that in mind next time
[ __ ] yes anything just Busey her time is
not even a factor your final time
[Music]
so now right after this yeah you have
like a few seconds where she doesn't
attack you that you didn't attack less
I'm just switched to regular grenades or
even the crossbow things yeah I would
say expand explosive arrows you got it
and just like literally just hammer okay
it's like the bugs aren't overwhelming
yet so you have a few seconds to [ __ ]
smoker
[ __ ] yeah I think I did a lot I hope so
and again I would do yeah that seems
better because this bugs are [ __ ] so
yeah and also on what you know your
phone sorry
don't one thing you need to watch out
the bugs are really not doing much
damage at all it's those tentacles and
when you run when you see the tentacles
move I think you were freezing last time
so try to stay in like no so so stay
toward this corner that's like kind of a
the bottom right I think I don't know
the tentacles can go there I guess just
keep moving
[Music]
I just crush it
did you yeah wait
okay something that was like a delay
between when you hit her and when you
got all these bugs damn those explosive
arrows [ __ ] her up they did are they
eating her oh [ __ ] no it's not over
she's gonna fly go get that thing sorry
it's not over at your but your your
toward the end this is just the third
the final phase all right confidence we
got confidence go get that [ __ ] thing
what okay so that thing has infinite
animal from what I remember he's go get
it you didn't use any help yet you're
you beat the game pretty much just go
[ __ ] her up I don't hope it doesn't take
two just unload on her Oh infinity
linear launcher she's flying I I don't
know I I think you have to oh [ __ ] its
first yeah you're in a very good spot
you you didn't use any help yet and I
don't think you're gonna get poisoned so
you use the green blue I hope you're not
late for sweet
[Music]
oh [ __ ] where is this stupid [ __ ]
[Music]
give me one give me two three four five
yeah [ __ ] you Veronica
[ __ ] you oh my god she hit you too at
the end
oh alright I'll admit I was nervous
about not having Magnum for maybe the
whole episode today move thank God for
those explosive arrows we almost didn't
bring those lot of happiness and sadness
well I thought I beat her when she like
came out for her second forum this game
not done this is it I think no this is
oh my god
done it's just a cutscene
god I need a drink after that I don't
normally did you skip that
oh no sorry that's loading oh that thus
concludes the longest season of Knievel
boy it's very good though I think it's
one of my favorites in this game yeah so
now it's a good boss fight I think it
just nervous like maybe not as good as
one that was a two-hour episode by the
lake and three no and seven but I think
it's better than three so now we got
zero oh [ __ ] we Felicia laughs that's it
sorry to disappoint you
[Music]
what is it I have Steve in his body
there's still a little T Alexia virus
Steve should be a good specimen
stop saying Steve maybe he'll come back
alone
and be able to see your sister again
don't you touch him I'm sorry
you get out of it they took Steve the
web app as a surviving member of stars I
can't
remember your promise
to live and stuff so Jill was in Raccoon
City fighting the nemesis pretty much I
think right now so ready
[Music]
I don't think
hi
[Music]
it might just be a cliffhanger because
what happens between between this and
five I think five the next time you see
Chris yeah I'm surprised this is number
system number activated it was supposed
to be in this area it was gonna be self
destruct system
I think it's nemesis oh yeah I don't
know it's a huge game it's also a
Dreamcast title originally don't haven't
found a place on Dreamcast I have a
Dreamcast in my apartment but it's just
going yeah oh I think she's gonna come
[ __ ] yep why is he will see you the
mid push ups
[Music]
hey we already killed him in a volcano
if you don't remember
god what a dumb part didn't we kill
Westar in six no that dude who took
forever was damned he did not do great
feat have not aged well in the polygonal
graphics era is this all a cutscene
[Music]
damn watch your eye beams where's Clara
hurts yet
hell yeah [ __ ] yeah
well I mean if that can't kill him you
ain't gonna kill him oh he's gonna
fistfight and that'll do it nice try
[Music]
God how many times need to die I always
liked those today's you're lucky
the burn marks and fives time we meet
you're lucky I can't jump over this
first may God hold you up doesn't
oh he totally does I know he doesn't he
looks fine maybe like God is so doping 5
the Fox and 5 now he's fighting
[Music]
what has she been doing this whole time
oh she's waiting for me
protect the Queen
you're never supposed eken elevator in a
fire you're always just experienced
homey we had a fire extinguisher Oh
[Music]
hurry up and take a look you know that I
always keep my promises yeah he earned
that
I think Clara knows how to fly a [ __ ]
Harrier Chris promise me please promise
that you won't leave me alone again I'm
sorry Claire asking for a live yeah
Jesus cling much so what happens after
this
[Music]
okay
I think reading will five kind of picks
up after this and then four is going on
yeah
[Applause]
thank you everyone for joining for the
last 16 episodes we're starting red evil
zero next week let me turn this down
I'll keep the credits rolling for these
fine people yeah if he joined us for
Code Veronica ordering and they went
back thanks so much
we're playing through originally the
plan was to play through all the
numbered games before seven came out and
that failed miserably well we got
through it just like a year late played
seven so the plan right now after this
is to do 0 we're gonna do resonable zero
in the origins collection on ps4 after
that revelations and revelations 2 we're
trying to finish them all I think we'll
easily finish those games before resin
evil to remake comes out in January
January 25th if we have time we'll
probably do the oft requested resonable
7 DLCs and then if we have more time
maybe dude Jake his campaign 6 but
that's like lowest priority because that
game is DLCs yeah yeah that's yeah
that's what saying but yeah I like to
god that feels so long ago that was a
long time ago when you first met Steve
and he's got those oh my god
I remember Steve for but we're will
probably have to play zero a couple for
a few hours before I leave for the New
York and then maybe a trip I was telling
about after that and not positive yet so
yeah
everyone thank you so much for joining
us always
[Music]
[Music]
that's poor oh yeah you could probably
get this now thank you everybody who
made this game skip it oh you can't what
song is this okay uh thoughts I'm
Veronica you what you were saying it
ranks pretty high it was really good I
do think that did it age well yeah I
think it's still very scary
there were some things that I think felt
a little long I don't understand how the
hell you do this about some kind of
cheats or guide because like the idea
that I was supposed to know half those
things like without you this would have
taken three five times well yeah it
might not have even finished like 25%
with me 75% was art dark commenters yeah
the the helpful commenters let me go
back to actually I want to update you on
the stats before how many times you died
this episode not many once from Steve
and once from Veronica wasn't bad -
right
so 17 deaths total 18 throughout the
season
not bad I mean go back to go Veronica
part that was part 16
people are wondering if you snorted coke
before the last episode oh you almost
reached you were at 198 kills before
this episode we started like oh no you
were just like very high energy so yeah
18 deaths I don't know how many people
you killed this uptick you broke 200
murders
Nathan Shepard who has been doing great
work even our stats chewed on by zoms
you up that a lot more health recovery
the same thing poisoning you up that by
one more you got poisoned ten times oh
wait all those poisons are from this
[ __ ] mods and then he said PS the
next episode might be a little stressful
but you guys have got this see you did
it took two hours and we beat the game I
told Mary yesterday at Exeter I was like
okay let's just beat the game this week
so yes and it's later than normal to 8
p.m. Pt yeah it's late but I think it
was worth it sticking it around because
I how much Mary did how much coffee -
Mary and Jessi apparently yeah sorry
about the crop on the last episode we we
had to use the studio the last two
episodes because we have show some love
to the crossbow oh hell yeah we did
game it's gave the crossbow the veronik
actually I'll tell you right now I think
like the stars that I had that crossbow
because that made that boss fight
infinitely easier like the difference
being that first boss fight and the one
I just did yeah
can we do a poll and we vote for next
resin evil so we've been promising zero
for a long time but and I've said resin
revelations of EXO revelations so you
know you could but I still think zero
we've been or anybody picked yeah not
zero then that would be a bummer because
we've been saying that well to zero okay
that's my score let's see oh that's all
the score I need
Atlee wait why is she wearing she's
wearing the same thing but he changed
out of his combat gear that's just what
she wears that's like her day-to-day can
you press something wait wait wait oh
say the back fragrance outlet sterk and
brew burger stock and barrel stuck in
the roof store can brew fragrance outlet
me wheat spall meets a poultry maybe
yeah I can you press something look at
this dude II didn't fail roof saves 30 -
hey we already know what stats thanks to
Nathan Shepard number of retries 21
what is retries deaths that can't be
right I guess I guess the game wouldn't
writing system that's like doesn't exist
hath there's no e in the American crazy
systems like see forever 0.9% and then
the professor's like I'm around that up
yeah I don't want to see the student
again next semester so I'm graduating
here that's how this game felt about you
okay there anything after this screen so
I don't know if you know it's ominous
battle Oh like battle game like you
battled hard to beat that Dan this game
is so code veronica was 2000 on
dreamcast I believe ps2 was covering X
all right yeah so revelations was
originally a 3d s and they brought it to
ps4 we're gonna play the ps4 version
Revelations 2 will play co-op I'll be is
a sherry with the flashlight I don't
know it's kind of a minor role but I'll
be playing with you but first we have
Rose Evil zero I'm gonna probably start
not tonight I'm kind of maybe tonight
but I'll play through that so I'm a
better guide for the next season okay
thank you guys for joining it so much
everyone that's another one god I'm the
bucket again well I'll I'll put in the
normal outro but just for that's a go
bye did it how many exactly nine nine
what games